it is determined that a given water
system requires softening due to the
amount of magnesium hardness present
excess lime is being added at 40 mg per
liter to a two-stage softening process
the concentrations of the ions found in
the water sample are given in the table
below how much lime will be required in
pounds of
CAO per million gallons of water treated
so this is the second softening problem
posted to this channel if you want to
see the other I will link it in the
description softening seems to be a
confusing topic for many people and I'll
be the first to admit that I'm not an
expert myself so let's break this
problem into small
steps the problem is asking for an
answer in terms of pounds per million
gallons of calcium oxide or
CAO first we need to identify the ions
on our list that are related to
softening these are going to be calcium
ca2+ carbon dioxide CO2
alkalinity and magnesium
mg2+ note that while CO2 does not
contribute to hardness it does consume
lime and so needs to be accounted for
the ions are given as concentrations in
milligrams per liter
however the problem is asking us to
solve for the amount of lime required in
terms of pounds of lime or calcium oxide
CAO so we first need to convert these
concentrations into Mill equivalents per
liter let's do this by gathering some
more information about each
ion Millet equivalent is calculated by
dividing the concentration that we are
given by the equivalent weight of the
ion
we have the concentrations so now we
just need to find the equivalent weight
this is available in the manual in
sections
6.1.5 point3 and
6.1.5
point5 equivalent weight is the molar
mass over the charge of the
ion and its units can be thought of as
millgram per Mill equivalent
so looking at the manual the equivalent
weight of calcium
ca2+ is
20 the equivalent weight of carbon
dioxide CO2 is
22 the equivalent weight of alkalinity
hc3 minus is already in milligrams per
liter as
cac3 this means that we
need the equivalent weight of cac3
instead of hc3 minus this value is going
to be
50 finally the equivalent weight of
magnesium
mg2+ is
12.2 and one more thing we also need the
equivalent weight of calcium oxide
CAO this one is also in the manual and
it's
28 so now that we have our equivalent
weight
let's divide the concentrations by these
numbers to get our M equivalence per
liter mil equivalent per liter is the
same as the milligrams per liter over
the equivalent
weight this can be thought of as the
relative react ability of the ions in
the
solution so 80 mg per liter divided by
the equivalent weight of
20 is going to give us 4 mil equivalents
per
liter 15 divided by 22 is going to give
us
0.68 130 ided 50 is going to give us
2.6 and of course 12.2 / 12.2 is going
to give us
1 once this is done we can sum up all of
these ions that are used and find our
total quote unquote react ability in mil
equivalence per
liter so 4 +
0.68 +
2.6 + 1 gives us a total of 8.28 mil
equivalents per
liter for step five we can convert this
reactable
number back to calcium oxide or Cao
that's why we took the equivalent weight
down of 28
before so multiplying
8.28 M equivalents per liter * 28 mg per
M equivalent will give us
231.50 mg per liter in this two-stage
softening
process so now that we are back in the
correct units we can add the 40 migr per
liter of
lime to our
23184 and this is going to give us a
total of
27184 mg per
liter for our final step we need to do
one final
conversion the problem asks for the
answer in terms of pounds per million
gallons the reference manual has a
conversion factor for
this and it is
8.34 pound per million gallons over mg
per liter so multiplying this conversion
factor times our
271.50
pounds per million gallons
and we can see that our answer is most
closely related to the fourth option on
our list of answers softening can be a
very difficult topic for a lot of people
myself included getting familiar with
the types of ions that are involved in
softening as well as the steps needed to
convert first to your Mill equivalence
and then to your final desired ion or
chemical will be a big help in getting
you on the right path to solving these
problems on the exam